[Music]
could the crisis over ukraine have been
averted in his column this week rod
little writes that we have had many
chances to neutralize russia's potential
threat they have all been passed up
to explain rod joins me now
now rod you write in your column this
week that the current russian aggression
is something that the west has fostered
and passed on opportunities to
ameliorate it's not a mainstream view so
can you explain it for us well it's it's
very simple through the course of
russia's history all the way back to the
cuban rus and the formation of russia
which was of course at the time ukraine
um
russia has periodically reached out to
the west desperate to be a part of the
western times and has on almost every
occasion been rebuffed um and
uh
this has usually resulted in the
russians then retreating into a kind of
slavic and and asiatic uh redoubt uh
where they uh stress their differences
to the west uh this certainly happened
so it happened under the stars and it's
happened under the soviet union and it's
happening now uh and the the idea about
joining nato
is is the perfect example of this
in 2000
vladimir putin
asked uh if russia could join nato
and was told uh this is according to
george robertson former uh labour
minister of course and former head of
nato uh it was talked about that
aerially by robertson though you know we
we don't uh uh
we don't invite people to join nato you
have to apply this is russia you know
this is rougher and vladimir putin
apparently said
in a very punitive way well look
we're not going to stand in line with
countries who
mean nothing whatsoever sort of thing
and so it never happened and indeed over
the next 10 years
putin became more and more distanced
from uh from the west
and thought that the west was perfidious
but he wasn't the first you know he
wasn't the first
uh russkie to
uh suggest that russia should join nato
uh boris yatsen uh in 1991 suggested
that
that russia should join nato
and did so again in 1993
and this was at a time when nato was
busy swallowing up poland and countries
like that and in fact yeltsin supported
um poland's membership of nato much to
the distress of the former commie
hardline as he was still hanging around
uh in the country and then in
1990 mikhail gorbachev uh proposed that
russia should one day very soon join
nato
but the u.s secretary of state at the
time said that this was merely a dream
and shouldn't be entertained
and so we we've had all these
all these uh overtures from the russians
and have rejected them each time the
first one i mean arguably the most
interesting one and one which probably
had a bit of mischief attached to it as
well was back in 1953 that the height of
the early cold war
when molotov
who was russian foreign secretary
foreign minister at the time
um also said look we'd like to join this
new organization nato we think it would
be
of cardinal importance for peace
throughout the world and particularly
security in europe
um and
it's interesting because at the time
winston churchill
was very very much in favor of
rapprochement uh with the soviet union
much to the annoyance of eisenhower uh
and the american administration and
churchill kept
pushing for a summit meeting with uh
khrushchev who was newly installed
um
or indeed melancholics who
proceeded krishna and that there should
be this big summit meeting with
eisenhower churchill
and uh and the soviet premier and that
this would lead to a thawing of
relations and and the threat of
worldwide annihilation receding but he
was always rebuffed on that occasion by
uh by the americans so there has been a
history
even then even in the cold war russia
was asking to join nato
well rod is fascinating because i
certainly didn't know about any of these
attempts and i think it's interesting
that people in the west don't tend to
hear about these overtures as you've
called them but do you think that we
should take any of these um moves
seriously because how much of it is as
we would say in the millennial
generation trolling you know how much of
it is mischievous and teasing uh nato
and western alliance i think there was
some mischief
with molotov uh because this was at the
time in 1953 nato was was very very new
uh i have been in existence a year i
think um
and
and there were questions about whether
the us should be in nato and um molotov
was arguing that both the us and and
russia should be in nato and there was
probably a bit of mischief involved
there sure
but there was no mischief involved with
gorbachev none whatsoever and certainly
not with the old suit nor was there any
reputation uh if you think back to 2000
um
russia
being accepted into nato would have
we would be in such a strong position
today if russia was in nato we wouldn't
have had the problems over ukraine and
we would have had a very very solid bull
walk against china
and indeed radical islam uh all of which
you know putin has previously
acknowledged the things which we in the
uh we and russia have in common
but we rejected it and we've always
rejected it and we rejected it you know
over the last 800 years
what we've tended to do instead is
meddle
in russian affairs uh in soviet affairs
back in 1917 we tried to to crush the
revolution um
invade the country the curve of russia
has been invaded by
uh by germany of course it was invaded
by napoleon um
and that that's kind of been the way
that the west has responded to the
russians so you can see when people talk
about the russians being paranoid
about
nato
uh swallowing up the likes of estonia
latvia lithuania poland uh uh ukraine uh
that that it feels as if it's encircled
well it is encircled uh and that
paranoia has roots has long long roots
in history and i just we have to
remember that i have no truck with putin
at all
and i think we have to stand up
for ukraine uh on this occasion what i'm
talking about is the history
between our two great blocks
the vast russian empire
and western europe
we have tended to russia has tended to
be more sinned against than sinning
do you think that um i mean i think your
point on china is particularly
interesting and i do agree with you that
what we seem to be doing right right at
the moment is pushing russia closer to
china and something that i've been
talking about on spectator tv just now
with james forsyth and the historian
robert service as well but you know
during the cold war nixon was able to
peel china away from russia and you know
overlook china's kind of communist
ideology but do you think ideology
stands too much in the way now between
the west and russia so could could the
west really peel russia away now given
the rhetoric on both sides and given
that putin is not really a democrat is
he
uh no he's not um he's an autocrat and
an authoritarian but the point you raise
is interesting
because
i can see nato eventually back in 1953
said no to russia the soviet union
joining for
reasons of democracy in other words they
said
the soviet union that was an ideological
difference that the soviet union
couldn't be part of it for ideological
reasons
and you can see that that that seems to
me to make sense of course by 1990 1993
there was no ideological difference uh
you know uh mikhail gorbachev wanted to
turn russia into kind of sweden and the
else is the same
now
and it would have been the same in 2000
as well uh where russia was not yet
the authoritarian state which it is
today
but since that rebuff
russia has done what it's tended to do
at times is look for allies elsewhere
and it's retreated exactly as it used to
do in the past into its it's it's it's
asian roots
which means asian-style democracy i.e
not what we would call democracy
uh the persecution of political
opponents
but equally uh uh
a move away
uh from
what putin considers to be the western
ideology at the moment which is uh the
culture wars uh so putin is very clearly
on one side of the culturals i have to
say i'm on the same side as him when it
comes to the culture
i think one of the the best domestic
one of the best speeches i read in the
last couple of years was putin's about
what the west is doing to itself
and he likened um
the policing of the culture wars in the
west to what happened under stalin in in
the soviet union uh and i'm with him all
the way on that but i'm not with him all
the way on murdering political opponents
and gerrymandering elections i think
that's pushing it a bit but you're right
that there is now a greater ideological
divide between us
and russia than their hand indeed china
than there has been since the end of the
cold war
[Music]
you